bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
français ce que le soutien aérien des
états unis peut selon vous aider les
forces armées afghanes à reprendre le
contrôle du pays
les militaires américains ont annoncé
aux mêmes et coco leur intervention pour
aider les forces de l'ordre afghanes ou
dernières gagnent en fait ce n'est pas
un engagement un réengagement des
etats-unis dans la guerre pour soutenir
l'armée afghane mais c'est pour soutenir
certains positions de l'armée afghane
pour empêcher que l'état demande avance
davantage c'est à dire qu en fait les
américains ne souhaite pas qu le rapport
de force se détériore d'une manière
extrêmement dangereuses entre le
gouvernement et les taliban à savoir par
exemple si l'idée temps devant avance
davantage à ce moment là mon mandat il
pourrait pouvoir les moyens d'attaquer
des grandes villes c'est sûr que des
american le web à merde tout malgré tout
est ce que ce soutien aérien mais pas un
revirement de la part de washington qui
annoncent depuis des semaines que les
soldats américains auront quitté
l'afghanistan fin août jusqu'où selon
vous est ce que les états unis peuvent
revoir leur position est ce que cela
vous semble nécessaire aujourd'hui
oui on a pensé en poulain et de cette
façon mais par contre lorsqu'on examine
en détail hde à cordes op signé l'année
dernière entre des américains et l'état
des bandes dans lequel il y a des
éléments qui autoriserait les american
intervenir d'une manière épisodique aux
côtés de l'armée afghane
à titre d'exemple selon cet accord les
tolérances sommes engagés d'or baisser
la tension
baisser la violence et ils ont donné
même l'assurance de ne pas attaquer des
grandes villes en amont l'instant c'est
à dire que si jamais il n'assume pas
cette partie de l'accord à ce moment
lille les américains tout en retirant
leur force dollar restant il pourrait
intervenir pour aider l'armée un gant à
partir de l'étranger par exemple
aujourd'hui où en sont les talibans dans
leur conquête de l'afghanistan après une
période extrêmement difficile pour
l'armée afghane une période de conquête
pour les temps les bandes où une grande
partie de territoire afghan
les comparer à bandes non non ce n'est
pas le centre ville pas les grands
progrès mais les talibans avaient coupé
un gros party et de l'administration
locaux en harmonie sans cas dans la
besace servir des districts
mais là de goudargues ans depuis
allemande est arrivé au point où ne
pouvait plus vraiment reculer c'est la
raison pour laquelle la il ya certains
tacles amis qui s'est instaurée c'est à
dire que de temps en temps le temps le
banc à lens la conquête d'un doudou ou
trois districts mais qu parade allemande
le gouvernement ne parvient également
entre guillemets libérer certains
industrie voilà lille tournai bon
essentiellement en garde ils ont alors
position lors conquête de ces et
d'autres dernières mois et en même temps
il s'englue dans une phase extrêmement
offensive et dangereux rose pour les
centres provinciaux ou les grandes
villes il ya encore une dizaine de jours
de négociations entre représentants du
gouvernement afghan et les talibans se
déroulait à doha excuse
résolution diplomatique de la situation
vous paraît encore possible oui il est
possible et d'ailleurs il doit une issue
négociée et parce qu'on va en temps de
guerre a montré qu il n'y a pas de
solution militaire pour cette guerre les
américains n'ont pas gagné la guerre
quand sur le plan militaire
ils ont même échoué c'est la raison pour
laquelle ils ont signé un accord avec le
louvre argoviens demande de démontrer
dans l'incapacité à maintenir sa
présence
ça m'a mise 2 sur l'ensemble de ares
hogan au contraire notre les talibans
montre une fois de plus comme ils sont
capables de prendre des initiatives sur
le plan militaire
donc en europe à continuer encore un
temps de guerre et cette fois ci entre
les argons où les principaux victimes
seraient des civils
c'est la raison pour laquelle oui il y a
des temps tentative d'abord langage
l'encouragement american août au grand
narbonne et aux talibans de négocier
ensuite il ya les pays de la région là
aussi la chine l'iran qui se sont
engagés également dans cette voie de
négociations entre l'auto paris et même
dernièrement terme et mostow et et
raymonde haute des talibans dans ce sens
c'est la raison pour laquelle est fou
qu'il négocie nez s'allonge
je monte sur quoi et voudrait négocier
c'est là que tout se complique mais fait
le coureur à gombe par deux points du
bouquet il faudrait qu en maintiennent
les avancées que nous avons tous ces
vingt dernières années en terme est de
de libertés publiques le devenir aussi
merci beaucoup pour votre éclairage
karim pakzad je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur à l'iris et spécialiste de
l'afghanistan